what are we doing on time we are oh my
god get to the point where Jenna dated
that we're not talking about racist
called you Jenna oh let's talk about him
[Laughter]
pizza ask for Jenna I'm gonna say this
this program is an hour bonus yeah
bonus you know [ __ ] we'll save it
for the next time [ __ ] you what's that
one what's the [ __ ] unhelpful advice
this is not unhelpful advice I didn't
read it though right so I'm hopeful
advice with Barbie
kalila hi Tiger belly I'm 28 years old
and I live in Pennsylvania I have a
house a car a wife a career money in the
bank account and a plan for the future
for the last 10 years of my life I've
been surrounded by people who are
battling their own personal demons
everyone has problems whether it's debt
relationship struggles and narcissism
anxiety jealousy substance abuse etc
after listen to many podcasts where
people admit their own failures and how
they're still working on it
sometime I've managed to address all of
my problems early in life well all of my
problems except for one I get the
feeling that when people reveal their
emotions whether it's exploding in
arguments fighting and doing other
self-destructive behavior as a result of
some sort of pain they're going through
others seem to find that very endearing
I've heard many podcasters talk about
how important it is to treat others the
way you'd like to be treated to be
content with what you have and be Zen
whenever you can whenever you can but
somehow I've headed the needed this
advice so much in my life that I get the
feeling that people find my lack of
suffering to be completely unrelated
where most people I know have been in
clean paws Keys lack of suffering he has
not had a hardship in his life it's
basically George Kimmel okay lucky boy
he says because I'm lost
yeah yeah yeah where most people I know
have been in crippling debt abuse from
their family
in other or other problems that
eventually sprout out of control in
their 20s and 30s I think it's become
very weird for other people to be around
me because I'm almost never in a
position of need or want nobody tells me
that I'm a sucky friend under that I
give off a comfortable vibe however I'm
inclined to believe that they're scared
of being honest with me I have a lot of
trouble connecting with people about
personal things but I don't have any
relatable problems cause he's not a
relatable person because he hasn't had
no hardships it's great and it's great a
distance between me and almost everyone
I meet that others with problems don't
seem to have do you have any thoughts
for this unicorn about the necessity of
having problems in life in order to be
more likable person nosotros papaya
tiger belly thank you George Kimmel is a
perfect example of how you have a great
upbringing a good life good parents no
drug abuse no nothing and he is a person
that we love we adore and we need and we
actually seek advice from I think that
even though we don't do that no I
honestly I don't [ __ ] really give a
[ __ ] what you have to say about anything
to you man to you it's like oh there's
that guy you know I try charge
I tried no no silence is a vortex that
traps the laughter I always remember
that and let me say something to you
right when you did it or vine you were
trapping laughter all right but in
silence but you never released it all
right you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] let me
say something right now to this guy
right George
good for you Picard in this shirt right
now referencing a reference this guy um
I really don't know what he's even
talking about okay let me give you a
quick synopsis yeah he doesn't feel like
his friends come to him for with with
their honest selves because he has had a
very like good life he's handled
problems he doesn't have any real issues
in his life he has money he has a good
family so people don't come to him and
say hey man like they don't talk to him
he feels like they don't no one ever
does that to me you know I like it that
way people don't come up to me got here
I have a problem they used to there used
to be a guy I'm gonna say his name and a
girl I'm not gonna say her name
but the guy was a kind of big comic
right the girl was a comic as well and
he used to beat her all right so I I'm
not saying names I know but I was on
stage I would be on stage and I would
you know at the improv or the comics or
whatever and from the cord in my eye I
would see her in the audience like off
to the side crying you know me maybe
she's a black eye and she'd be like
waiting for me to get offstage to give
her advice right I used to be that guy
but no longer because people walk all
over you I don't think so I think they
do when I'm the guy that when I'm the
guy that people like oh let's see what
Bobby has to feel how it feels about
this or I'm going through a problem they
[ __ ] use you okay so now I'm a closed
book I'm just like you friend but you
know what I like about somebody I'm just
a assuming this guy is similar to you
what I like about you is that George
because he has no judgments I can tell
him anything and everything and he's
never he's never had you know yeah yeah
yeah that's what I like do like that
about you he's not like ooh that never
happened to me yeah I don't think that
just because you haven't gone through it
that people can't make use of whatever
wisdom you have and a lot of times
people are just saying things because
they just want to hear you have an ear
to talk to I also not necessarily well
advice you just want to get off your
chest yeah I think some of it might be
in his own head that yeah he's
separating himself from other people
thinking I haven't had hardships I
haven't had this I haven't had that and
that in and of itself is gonna
energetically separate him from people
wanting to come to him
like I I wonder if people are coming to
him being like nah man I just don't come
to you because you can't relate
or if he's the one doing that B maybe he
feels like he can't relate to them right
and that's okay people want you to be
empathetic for you to listen you can't
solve their [ __ ] like I didn't have a
hard upbringing people come to me for
everything yeah it's just understanding
and making people feel like they're
comfortable and like their [ __ ] is valid
yeah or like you're not gonna be [ __ ]
a snotty judgey [ __ ] about anything
that they come to you with you know yeah
you're gonna make it Janna's gonna make
I really believe that you're gonna make
it and not as a hydrogen atom no more
than that thank you
you're gonna fist your neck nasty vag
fix it oh I said fist
you're gonna fist in then fix it she
already fizzes it once I get them on no
I can't fist it yeah yeah so you're
gonna you're gonna fix that [ __ ] you're
gonna book in this next year something
big I can feel it I can feel it too I'm
gonna light a few can no I don't even
need to light the candles you're gonna
book big sub book something big okay I'm
gonna make predictions for everyone in
the room actually okay Gilbert at the
end of the year you're gonna book a
really good guest starring on a big TV
show I hope so
George know that go to kalila kalila
battle long beach revival yeah Reba
you're gonna come up with a series of
MMA videos where you said what he wants
for him you're gonna it's gonna be stop
and go you're gonna be cross-eyed you're
gonna be sweating a lot right and we'll
feed you the lines I don't think right
George this year you're not gonna die
you're gonna live for the rest of the
year
congratulations that's so good
Bryce you're gonna get back into stardew
valley and you're gonna create a farm
that's gonna bury my farm
you know what Bryce told me when I
walked in today sorry to cut you yeah
mindlessly he just on his way to giving
me a hug he was like how are you look
good today you look like [ __ ] wash your
hair kalila I'm going to say something
really something big is gonna happen
this year where it's gonna it's gonna
it's gonna it's gonna revive it's gonna
revive your soul it's gonna be real it
yeah I think that I am in desperate need
of revival yeah it's gonna happen I'm in
a very eminent impasse in fact everyone
listening right now to this podcast you
you're getting blessed by slept King my
immigration about it and their alibi
attended by a new Limburger a hundred
this entire Arab on didn't buy any Andy
yeah III die truth that's true that's me
speaking in tongues think I am god bless
you take care I got a I got a leave and
he shows for Bobby
[Music]